خلال يومين فقط توجه نحو الفي شخص الى
مركز قصر الحوريات بدرعه متقدمين بطلب شطب
اسمائهم من الملاحقات القانونيه والامنيه
طامحين الى استصدار وثائق واوراق شخصيه
لممارسه حياتهم بشكل طبيعي النائب عن
محافظه درعا احمد سويدان يرى ان التسويه
فرصه لكل من اعاقه الظروف تسويه اوضاعه
سابقا سواء كان متخلفا عن الخدمتين
الالزاميه والاحتياطيه ام فارا من الجيش
ما هي فرصه للشبان اللي ما قدروا يعملوا
تسويه
سابقه وشايفين الاقبال كبير جدا جدا
والتسويه هي اجراءاتها مبسطه جدا اللجنه
الامنيه في محافظه درعا بصت كل الاجراءات
وبسبب الازدهام الشديد والاقبال الشديد
على هذه التسويه
ممكن تتمدد لبعد يوم الخميس ويفتحوا مركز
تسويه ثانيه وتهدف تسويات الى منح
المتخلفين عن الخدمه العسكريه فرصه العوده
الى مواقعهم السابقه وانهاء التوتر السائد
في محافظه درعا جنوبي سوريا والتي اندلعت
فيها شعله المظاهرات المعارضه منذ اكثر من
12 عاما واليوم
مبادره الطيبه واني جاي وجاي بابني وهذا
ابني معي ابني مطار حلب بالامن الجوي
وبده يرجع لقطعته وبده يرجع ياخذ الوطن
واحنا ابناء الوطن ويرجح مسؤولون السوريون
تمديد استقبال الطلبات لايام اخرى مع
احتماليه فتح مركز اخر بسبب الاقبال
الشديد للراغبين في التسويه نور الحصني
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات